when you hear the shot what does that
mean to you the shop I've been doing
here over 50 year been a barber since
1989 I'm like that it's the only shop
everything what lady named it after
yourself I can take no better person I
came up when you go to a barber shop you
go for not only haircut knowledge the
Wilson respect all those things we're
not only barbers we're here to educate
you who needs it you to advise students
try to be the best they could be a
positive image that's what is up i
didn't start getting haircuts to like my
senior high school me and my friends
would basically schedule him at the same
time and it was kind of like a little
social events a place to talk sports top
girls talk everything i have cheated on
my barber I cheated on him at like a
shop that was nearby and it was like
legit insecurities like worried I was
gonna run into him so I went and the
other do cut my hair but it felt dirty
there's a great significance the
barbershop and black culture sometimes
it's a good place to come get your
opinions out it's like you gotta have
jokes so you got to be prepared to get
roasted and it's kind of intense I feel
like it just is a culture but it I mean
it might vary a little bit from shop to
shop but for the most part you can
expect to be entertained somewhat
socially as much as you're going to get
you know your haircut I remember when I
got the whole idea to become a barber I
was in grade school that cut hair
he didn't play basketball he played
football and I'm like that he was the
Barbarian like that's what everybody
knew him for he's first person I looked
up to lay in a different world I told
him one day in a library you're the one
who inspired me to be a barber I don't
know where I would be in life right now
if it wasn't for me cutting hair so it's
like I kind of only all this do that's
love right there man an energy exchange
is very important when I grew up the
barbershop is where little boys went to
basically kind of learn how to be mean
you kind of grow up in the barber shop I
mean you learn a lot just in sitting and
listening we couldn't go to say white
barber shops we needed that place to
feel safe the barber shop is where
man can go to be man away from gonna
send the women and we can talk about the
things that we really want to talk about
whether it's women sports sex cars you
know me kind of get to be who you really
are in the barbershop cuz no one's here
to judge that's what makes the
barbershop fun you don't want to go
anywhere where you can't have fun you
can't be yourself in the energy the
energy that's going on inside the shop
there's very intense well at time just a
little it's a little intimidating you
know when you walk in especially if
you're looking a little goofy but once
the once the cut was done I knew I was
fresh that's another reason I love being
a barber is like being able to give cats
that confidence I mean after you get a
fresh cut you know the confidence that
somebody walks out of a barber shop with
being able to give people that hey I
love that man that's why a lot of cats
come to the barber shop don't even need
haircuts they'll just come there for
that environment a barber shop is a
place to really kind of hone in on that
because we are a community and that's
that's kind of what we're here for
you can like see their pitches I started
out taking pictures so what kids so they
give it to their parents go when I was
coming up I guess we couldn't afford
cameras and missing hair and yeah
outside doing nothing passed them out to
the kids or whoever don't have no
picture of us ever they were young you
know pictures hold memories and I'd like
to look at him sometimes and think what
I was doing at that time this is
actually the first barber shop I
remember being in like everybody
definitely has a barber shop but the way
that we do the barber shop is completely
different as I look around just it's
it's so much that it's very unique to
this space this black space everything
that the Barbara is they put on these
walls and it helps attach themselves to
the heritage but also attach themselves
to their practice I think yeah this is a
museum a gallery space minute so
really does especially the older guy
need to do more to what I answered I
love people if I could help anyone
I'm boy got race creed color you know
that's what it's all about to me yeah
not only out people it's for all people
[Music]
dear wherever 267 I stood establish a
little bit more wealthier now